kids working with adults can either go
horribly wrong or really well the child
cast of harry potter proved to be a
great bunch let's get a look at some of
the students and professors funniest
bloopers during their time behind the
scenes
number one we'd like to think daniel
radcliffe had all the best training for
harry potter
[Music]
we guess all the dance training in the
world couldn't save him in this scene it
is just a rehearsal according to him
though it was just him really embodying
the character because harry's not very
good
doesn't matter anyways he's a champion
through and through
i'm actually attempting number two
one
two three professor mcgonagall on the
other hand can dance like a pro put your
hand on my your right hand on my waist
on my waist we knew she wanted to make
rupert grant squirm in front of his
classmates and it definitely worked now
you will have to lead eventually
understood
number three kids during long film
shoots can get pretty bored very quickly
hello
here
and a bunch of ten-year-olds all cooped
up together means a lot of pent-up
energy
the adults on set were super cool about
it though even joining in on the fun
themselves
this is david given a lesson in slaps
number four sometimes working with kids
can get a little frustrating especially
for the adult co-stars
they just kept to themselves while the
crew wrangle up a massive crowd of
energized kids and then this one boy on
the gryffindor table comes around and
goes
we think the only professor on cue for
keeping to himself was snape he could
have at least
number five
still rolling hold your head up poor dan
just had a really hard time holding his
head up
and this just kept on happening same
problem different day dan remember to
announce it keep your head up couldn't
the director just give him a break he's
got a pretty heavy horcrux scar that's
just gotta hurt all the time
[Music]
number six accidents can happen even to
the best of the best
alan rickman wasn't known for having
many accidents on set and this hit was
pretty hard considering it broke the
camera and his wand
there is no one
more powerful
everyone got a good laugh out of it at
alan's expense
number seven rupert was notorious for
his laughing fits during scenes
you just saw your mouth yeah ronald
weasley just couldn't help but chuckle
even in the serious moments
rupert you shouldn't be laughing at the
end when you find out that dan's gonna
potentially be killed by say these
cracks were attempted to be concealed by
grint but it never seemed to work rupert
will start giggling and you pretend he
isn't giggling what a goofball
number eight now it's time for another
take on the set goofball this time the
professor edition
[Music]
no surprise here that robbie coltrane
gave the actors and crew an absolute
wild time between scenes
number nine poor ron just really takes
things to a whole new level
[Music]
you can see the fear in emma's eyes as
rupert barrels towards her and the best
part ron thinks he's the victim of all
this
she can take it though but the others
were not going to let ron down from this
blunder
number 10 michael gambin loved fooling
around behind the scenes and now he had
a partner in crime completely our own
world
you know all they wanted to do was
embarrass radcliffe in front of his
crush really really funny and for you
and um and let's not forget that the
director really didn't have time to
waste so this was a verified essential
prank to get a chuckle out of snape
[Music]
it's completely our own world and
number 11 siblings fight a lot
but fred and george were simply not
selling an entertaining brawl
[Applause]
that's when director mike newell stepped
in to show him exactly how it's done
noel whipped the boys back into shape
but probably regretted it afterwards he
was hobbling around for about four days
afterwards number 12. isn't it wonderful
seeing the professors getting along yes
maggie smith and emil de stanton were
on-screen enemies but definitely never
ever goofed between takes
[Music]
disloyalty oh
hey we'll take whatever preparation is
needed even when it makes dolores switch
up her lines a bunch
things are far worse than my feet than
i'd imagined then i feared
number 13 we are now witnessing the
early concept of a harry potter musical
in the making my name is gary my name is
gary
rupert and dan were just occupying
themselves on a chaotic set and casually
directing the cameraman you've got to
switch from him to me okay
they're definitely on key with this
moment
number 14
the music making doesn't end with the
kids and picks up with one of the
jokester professors
that's the great michael gambon sharing
a musical moment with the chosen one
though they've got plans to take their
talents elsewhere they're my god they're
gonna go busking in column garden in our
costumes guess the actors paychecks were
a little too light that week
number 15 ratcliffe really had a rough
time hitting his marks on set
[Music]
we've actually figured out the reason
why he's still not looking up
[Music]
missing your marks may cause an angry
crew-like atmosphere and potentially a
hand injury
number 16 you really don't want to mess
with the most powerful wizard even if
you're the chosen one
sorry dumbledore really just couldn't
get a break in the half-blood prince but
now his robe gets stepped on we see what
you're doing daniel time to get payback
number 17 a first kiss can either go one
of two ways
[Music]
or
something
this experience for them was probably a
little awkward but absolutely adorable
to us
it's cool now they seem to nail it on
the first take but why not make them
snog just a few more times
well i'll kiss you enough today we've
done it now it's done there we go number
18 alan rickman was so into his snape
performance that it really scared the
students
already was so fantastic i was freaked
and rupert was scared he actually
brought the snape out of rickman when he
drew a lovely portrait of him during
potions class the picture wasn't nice
either i think i exaggerated a few of
his features as funny as it would have
been for alan to scold the young artist
he instead was so amazed by his talent
and even kept it i have it in my
possession and i'm very fond of it
number 19. oh this one's got to hurt but
i am close
i'm kidding okay sorry you're laughing
because you hit me so hard
emma really does go all out to sell his
stun even if it means doing it for real
quite a lot
number 20. brendan gleason made mad eye
moody into quite the drill sergeant at
hogwarts constant vigilance constant
vigilance but deep down he was just
another goofy professor
he brought up all the moods of the
students and still managed to scare them
on camera gleason makes me laugh so much
number 21.
ladies and gentlemen
maybe this one was just a little too tmi
for harry potter fans bill
look away
i'm idiots
you think it was awkward for us try
telling that to poor ratcliffe who
really had to make it real
fantastic in women's globe imagine
changing in front of all the crew but
honestly that wasn't the worst part for
him dance hit the gym to prepare man
number 22 mad eyes back with another
blooper too funny to pass up on
gleason got more of a laugh from this
one than his younger co-stars and who
wouldn't be laughing watching a fake
ferret at the end of a pole dance around
there's a lot that went into the harry
potter film franchise and to help with
all the stress of putting together so
many actors fun and games who would have
thought the most serious characters
weren't at all serious behind the scenes
what pranks would you have pulled off if
you were passing time on the harry
potter set
leave a comment below
[Music]